[Music]
Center well senior Primary Care the
sponsors of this segment they're
simplifying the annual enrollment period
process for you I know it can get
complicated I spoke to a doctor to break
it all down
Dr Wakefield welcome back well nice to
see you Rocky always good to see you
we're talking annual enrollment period
it is that time so let's just educate
our viewers on what that means exactly
so every fall current uh Medicare
patients receive an annual notice of
change which is a letter outlining
upcoming changes to their coverage
Medicare beneficiaries are then eligible
to make changes to their coverage during
the annual election or enrollment period
or AEP for short which runs from October
15 to December 7th any changes they make
will then take effect January 1st now
what kind of changes can they make
during this period
well AEP is the only time of the year
when you can pick a new Medicare
Advantage or prescription drug coverage
plan depending on where they live
seniors can do a number of other things
during this period including switch from
original Medicare to Medicare Advantage
by a Medigap policy to help pay for
original Medicare switch their part B
prescription drug plans or opt out
completely
now what's the difference between the
annual enrollment period and the open
enrollment period I'm sure a lot of
people ask about that absolutely
Medicare Advantage open enrollment
period or oep for short is from January
1st to March 31st this period now has
more restricted options first to
participate in oep you must already be
enrolled in a Medicare Advantage plan
then you're limited on what you can
change for example you can switch from
Medicare Advantage back to original
Medicare join a Part D prescription drug
plan or switch to a different Medicare
Advantage plan but you can only make one
change during oep now why is it
important for seniors to make sure they
enroll in during AEP versus oep
well despite calling itself the open
enrollment period oep is quite
restrictive seniors who want to explore
more options and feel free to change
their minds more than once should really
participate in AEP for nearly two full
months you can do your research consult
professionals or you know to ensure that
really you have the best plan in 2023
that meets all your needs including
coverage for your own primary care
physician think of oep more as a chance
to take corrective action if you feel
you've made a mistake during AEP
ah okay it is very complicated topic was
so important for our seniors to know so
thank you guys for for keeping them up
to date it's my pleasure yeah if viewers
have any questions or want to learn more
visit
centerwelllasvegas.com or call the
number on your screen
um to find really the nearest Center
well senior Primary Care Center our care
teams are here to help you answer all
your health related questions
thank you Central well senior primary
care for sponsoring that segment they
have 11 locations across the Las Vegas
Valley so for more head to
centerwelllasvegas.com